As far as the women's rights in Islam is
concerned,
I have divided
this topic
into six categories.
Number one, the spiritual rights of
women in Islam,
the economic rights of women in Islam,
the social rights of women in Islam,
the educational rights of women in
Islam, the legal rights of women in
Islam, and the political rights of women
in Islam.
First we'll discuss
the spiritual rights of women in Islam.
There is a common misconception in the
western world
that in Islam
paradise
does not belong to the woman. A woman
cannot enter paradise in Islam. This is
a common misconception in the western
world. One verse of the Quran is
sufficient to dispel this myth. Allah
says in the Quran in surah Isa chapter
number four verse number 124
if anyone does righteous deeds
be it a male or a female
and has faith
he shall enter paradise
and not the least injustice will be done
to him.
A similar message is repeated in surah
Nahal chapter number 16 verse number 97
where it says if anyone does any good
deed be a male or a female
and is a believer
they shall enter paradise
and they shall be rewarded for all the
good they do.
Allah says in the Quran in Isa chapter
number four verse number one.
Oh humankind reverence your Lordian God.
Reverence your Lord and God who has
created you from a single person
and created like nature his mate.
This verse is clear that the spiritual
nature of the man and woman the male and
the female in Islam is the same.
Allah repeats the message
in surah arav
chapter number seven verse number 9 that
Allah has created
the human beings from a single person
and created like nature his mate and has
put love between the hearts.
Allah repeats the message
again
that he has created the human beings
from a single person and created like
nature his mates and from them he made
the daughters and the son and from them
the grandchildren.
Allah says in surah shar chapter number
42 verse number 11
Allah says
earth Allah has created the heaven and
the earth
and has created you
amongst yourselves in the same nature.
That means the spiritual nature of men
and women male and female is the same.
Allah says in surah hijar chapter number
verse number 29
that
he has made you in due proportion and
has breathed his spirit into you.
A similar message is repeated in surah
sagda chapter number 32 verse number 9
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
created you talking about Adam
created you in due proportion and has
breathed into him his spirit now here
when Allah says that he has breathed his
spirit into the human being it doesn't
mean any sort of god incarnation
or any sort of pantheistic religion
It doesn't mean any sort of god
incarnation or any sort of pantheism.
It mainly refers that Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala has given his knowledge to the
human beings both men and women.